hello everyone and welcome to Game three
of the 2018 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano
caruana if you haven't seen game 1 and
game 2 I will put a link to them in the
description below a very nice games if
you do want to check them out the result
is still even as both the game 1 and
game 2 were drawn but we before we dive
straight in the game 3 I do have a very
nice story to tell you as I was still in
London yesterday obviously I've arrived
back to Croatia I tried to organize a
little get-together I was contacted by
David Hill he's uh
well he's a reporter for for the ringer
it's an American sports publication he
asked me if he could ask me a few
questions about chess and you know in
general everything that is going on in
the chess world about my channel and
such and I said yeah you know sure it
might be might be a very nice idea and
he said that we should meet in the
Knights bar the Knights bar in London
that's in its Simpsons industry and I
posted about it as a YouTube post also
in my Facebook and Twitter accounts and
well I had no idea if any we would
actually show up since I I didn't really
announce it very early I maybe give it
like a 2 hour room for you to decide
whether to come or not so I was very
impressed about how many of you came and
here we do have a couple of photos from
yesterday here is a photo of well not
all of the people that were there but as
some of them had had to leave how we
decided to take a group selfie here but
more people have arrived later and you
know it's been very nice we had a couple
of beers not everyone some of them had
coffee or juice obviously we play some
chess games and we had a lot of fun got
to know each other you know it was a
very fun because two of the people that
arrived actually went to high school
together and well I didn't know that the
other one was gonna come so there was
also very enjoyable and one of the other
things that's also super interesting is
that it's in London or all of these
people are
Londyn more or less and none of them
have ever been to this bar in in that's
like a subway street or something like
that I don't know if it's called like a
subway street but it's like a Sawa
general area and they said we don't
really go there they're all that much
since it's fairly expensive and I also
had no idea what to expect and David
Hill who invited me there is from the
United States so basically we discovered
this very nice bar that has a beautiful
chess history you have a photos framed
of a lot of famous grandmasters who were
there not only not only British
grandmasters but also there was a very
nice framed photo of Viktor Korchnoi
and the bartender well first when we
arrived we first I have arrived first
then one person join me then we had a
sit and then as more people started
coming there were too many of us to fit
in one room so the bartender decided to
open up another room specifically for us
that room was not in use and he set up
the chessboard for us I was very nice
and you know really really thank you for
being such excellent subscribers let's
check it out one more time and as I did
say a lot more people know well not a
lot more but more people did show up
here is also a very nice photo of a
Michael John Buckingham and myself
Michael is one of my oldest subscribers
he you've seen him on my channel before
during the last years subscribers video
he sent a very nice three photos when
one of the photos was with his cat which
I very much remembered but yeah later he
helped me out too you know getting
getting a cab and stuff and also he took
me to to a very nice well he's it's like
an oldest wine bar in London so we came
there we checked it out didn't stay very
long but it was very nice so thank you
Michael for that as well and also I do
have a very special photo here is a
selfie of me and well obviously a
chessboard but it's a very special
chessboard because there on the chess
board you you see a little sign and it
basically says all of the players that
have played there but since you can't
read the sign
I took the liberty of taking a separate
photo that will show you how many of the
famous players have played here so there
you have it let's see an original chess
board and men in use at Simpsons in the
Strand as since 1826 so and played upon
by the following champions
Howard Sultan Johannes Tucker torte
Joseph Henry Blackburn as Egbert Arash
we have Tinsley Paul Morphy Ginsberg
whenever a chicken in Immanuel asked her
will him Stein it's Henry Byrd
we have Mason yanovskiy and the last one
we couldn't decide was it actually
Raymond Keane but I don't know any are
keen other than Raymond Keane so perhaps
it was so it was a it was a really a
beautiful piece of history that none of
us knew that was even here David Hill
the person who who came to interview me
he read about this Knights bar in the on
the internet and he thought it would be
a good idea to meet meet here and
actually uh Adolph Anderson's a student
Johannes Tucker torte actually well as
the story goes so the way he read it he
actually died in this bar while well
either playing chess there or maybe
having a drink there or who knows what
who knows why and also it was interested
interesting that Paul Morphy when he
came to challenge however Stanton he
actually came to this bar to challenge
him and well you all know the story
Stanton didn't want to play he was ill
and then the magic happened but still
more if he did play a few games at that
bar so really a remarkable piece of
history history and I'm incredibly glad
that I I saw it and if any of you have
the opportunity do check it out you know
it's the Knights Bar what's what's not
to like there's now there's beer and you
know the bartender's will even set up
the boards for you and also for the
final photo of this
well storytelling here we have a very
nice photo of myself and the mr. Kevin
and Henry Tran well I had a like an hour
and a half
before actually going to the night of
our so I decided to walk around London
it was very nice all the streets were
closed as there was like this huge
ceremony and I heard some guy playing a
violin and it was it was really
beautiful and I decided to go to go
closer to check out you know what what
he was doing there well obviously he was
playing a violin but it was so beautiful
I I just decided to go there and when I
approached him then these two guys
approached me and they were like hey man
you're I got matter I was like yeah and
then they were like hey we're fans and
what they knew fairly a lot about me and
then mr. Kevin he said that well he
watches my videos every day well while
eating breakfast so I thought it was a
very cool had a very nice chat with them
there they're also doing YouTube but
they are a french channel for comedy so
if you're you know if you understand
French and you know you like you like to
laugh do check them out and thank you
for for mentioning me regarding that
well it's in French but there's like a
little translation in there I feel like
chess check her chain she kills
obviously Microsoft Bing isn't all that
great in translating French but okay a
very enjoyable date to say the least now
getting back to the game it's Game three
Caruana again has the white pieces in
the first game working at the white
pieces cousin really came prepared he he
outplayed him in the opening and then
Khurana basically just had to suffer for
for a long 7 hours here we do have a
couple of photos again complemented by
Nikki Riga there we have magnus carlsen
it's also a very nice opportunity for us
to just check it out and you know if
you're feeling inspired maybe you can
even capture in the photo as it's not
all that clear what what he's looking at
but you know it depends on what kind of
a day you're having also here we have a
very nice photo of Fabiano writing
writing down all the moves and also on a
photo challenge well not a photo
challenge we could call it a money
challenge do how many of you know how
much money Fabiano spent actually costs
and here we have a third photo of this
very nice gentleman making the first
move at this time at the Woody Harrelson
wonder did not happen it was just the
genuine move if any of you know who the
gentleman in question is do share in the
comments section below so yeah it's a
bit of a longer story than usual but I
mean it was so enjoyable and I'm so very
glad that so many of you came that I
just had to share it so now let's check
out this very nice game Caruana has the
white pieces and he opens with E 4 we
have C 5 the Sicilian defense like in
game 1 and we will be following moves by
game they were played in game 1 so for
now Coulson doesn't go bye-bye fishers
technique as we've seen when we were
covering Fisher versus passkey that
Fisher never allowed for the same line
to happen but ok Knight to f3 Knight to
c6
we have Bishop to b5 the energy Medina
rosalie mo attack g6 bunch of captures D
captures this is the same as it was
played in game 1
d3 Bishop to g7 and here it's actually
Fabiano who defers from the game one
here he plays castles and ok Queen to c7
by Carlsen we have rook to e1 developing
the rook we have E 5 now a similar idea
as in game 1 and now a 3 not even
bothering with H 3 that was played in
game 1 but here the other pawn is played
and here you can see that the white is
definitely preparing b4 to challenge
this structure Carlson has on the Queen
side and even though those pawns are our
double that they're actually quite
useful for you know controlling the b4
and d4 square and it's just a second for
some reason the innervate if the
interface interfaces seems to have
shifted that once again so let me just
take care of that seems to be happening
quite often lately and I have no idea
why but okay that seems to have done the
job alright so guarding b4 and d4 and
here okay Carlsen goes Knight to f6 and
immediately Caruana
challenges it with before so what do you
do here
Carson
like castles and he offers the c5 pawn
and this will kind of be the theme of
this game can you actually capture on c5
if you capture on c5 here what would be
the idea well you could go after the
point immediately with Knight study
seven and then if whites the whites
tried to defend it would rush of - III
didn't black could start an attack with
f5 and well luck would get a decent
amount of activity for the price of one
phone for example if white captures then
even G can capture and it would it would
definitely be okay for black I even the
King can come to h8 maybe maybe the rook
can also we use the semi open G file and
with the wood the bishop bear Carlsen
definitely wants to open up lines so
Corona doesn't capture the pawn instead
he goes Knight B to d2 Bishop to g4 by
Carlsen and here we have h3 challenging
Carlson's bishop on h3 on g4 and here a
lot of commentators said that this was
actually one of the moments where it's
really a question and I mean surely they
came prepared especially Fabiano if he
he had to prepare something to improve
on Game one but would it be Capra's on
c5 here how can black make use of this
well if if we try the similar idea like
Knight to d7 like previously and the
white goes Knight to b3 to defend it
this way then you can go f5 and again
after you make a move either you will
capture on f5 and then black will just
simply recapture but if you just develop
the rook for example taking advantage of
the semi open file getting it away from
a1 as the bishop is well at some point
it might become dangerous then you would
get F captures on e4 pawn captures and
now Bishop captures an f3 the rook is
now protecting the bishop so you can't
capture with the Queen you have to mess
up your pawn structure and again it's
it's very hard to say would this Knight
now be able to go on a maneuvering trip
like Knight f6 to h5 to f4
where black would have to either allow
it to stay on f4 white would have to
allow it to stand F forward from where
it would control g2 and e2 or would
whites
the capture and most likely give up his
dark square bishop but then black would
be the only one with the dark square
bishop this pawn would free the bishop
and well since black does have counter
play but as Quran decided not to do it
actually he did take all of this into
consideration so kh3 challenging the
bishop and here we have bushel captures
on f3
we have Knight captures on f3 and here
Grichuk mentioned that this is a similar
structure that you would get out of the
out of the Berlin but it's it's only a
question of how much better white is
white is better but it's just a question
of how much better is he
and okay see chapter son before here a
Crossin could try a lot of different
moves but he still decides to eliminate
this threat of B captors and c5 once and
for all because it's interesting if you
for example developer look it maybe
would make sense to play something like
rook a to d8 simply getting that rook
into the game but here after big
captures on c5 after the Queen's Queen
attacks it now you would get rook to be
one with the idea that if Queen captures
here then rope would capture on b7 but
here after root blocks and now Bishop to
d2 this is the problem now bishop can
guard the c5 pawn indirectly now you
obviously can't capture because you
would lose the exchange here so although
it seems more natural to play something
like something like rook rook F to d8 it
would be much better to actually after
Knight captors on f3 play something like
rook a to d8 but still it would be very
dangerous after pawn captures on c5
will there be any compensation for the
c5 pawn for example Queen e7 guarding
attacking the pawn rook b1 not comes to
room d7 and now after Bishop to d2
Queen captures yeah that's the line
we've already shown unfortunately sorry
about that yeah and basically the rook
cannot stay stay there I seem to be a
habit start from my trip but yeah this
rook has to move to d8 but even if this
is played then bush
to g5 a very nice developing move and
now after something like c4 it's still
still gonna be okay for white because
after d4 you would either capture and
after ecaps or somebody for you would
get a five of course which would lose
you the exchange or if you don't if you
try something like h6 challenging the
bishop bishop to h4 you could try g5
rush up to g3 but still you're not
you're not really doing anything as
black here it's still it's a very very
powerful position for white so after
considering for a while costs and
decides to capture it C capture some
before we have Punk a person before and
now a5
I don't know is this the exact moment I
don't think it is but at some at some
point in the game I've seen a lot of
people tweeting on Twitter about cross
and touching his touching a piece and
then not playing with a piece but rather
playing with a pawn and then there was a
this fuss about this he say sure do did
he not say sure Dube and and it was
really funny since you did polgár is
commenting and she had a similar
situation with Gary Kasparov she also
mentioned that during the the livestream
and if you haven't seen that game I will
also put a link to that game in the
description below where that whole
incident happened but okay ABI
characters on a5 rope captures on a five
and now birds up to d2 later in an
interview in a short interview karana
said that he considers this Bishop to d2
to be a weak move but the engine doesn't
really I think it's I mean it's it's a
normal fine move rook to e8 he moves
that you could also capture but then
after rook captures an a1 Queen captures
nice to d7 to increase protection of
this 'if I've square its it would be a
slightly better position for white as
you can no longer take advantage of the
open a file for the rook as nothing
would be guarding it there
so instead after Bishop to d2 rook eight
to eight he goes back and now comes
Queen to be won by Caruana
Knights the d7 by Carlsen we have Queen
to b4
active square for the Queen also the
queen is now developed the rooks are
connected and now rook FTE 8 by Carlsen
perhaps something like c5 could also be
an idea where you could argue okay that
maybe if queen c3 then you could push
something like b5 the problem is if you
play see five queen bee five and now
there's really nothing to do to get this
Queen away from there after something
like b6 you would simply weaken your
light squares and not not really achieve
all that much
so after Queen to b4 we have look F to
e8 bishop to c3 and now we have b5 and
maybe this was the position where cross
and I believe he wiggled this night a
bit you know just you know improve it or
centralize it and then he decided to
play the pawn move but not sure rook
captures on a8 karana decides to
exchange rooks with rook captures and
now rook to e1 offering to exchange even
another pearl rooks Carlsen applies a
rope captures and they want Bishop
captures and now Queen to e7 attacks the
bishop on a one Bishop to c3 and now
comes the Queen to a2
now black is a bit more active here
the queen is also threatening to capture
the c2 pawn so you do have to do
something about this Quran Allah decides
to play Queen to be to offers the trade
of Queens and the Kos and goes for it we
have Queen captures and Bishop captures
and here f6 so now we've entered this
endgame where the material is completely
equal both players have a dark score
vegetable players have a knight but
black will be somewhat better as he does
have this night that can Riemann over
itself over to e6 and e7 e every strong
square from there the night will also
control f4 will control d4 and it will
be a very powerful piece will this be
enough well we'll just have to check it
out a king to f1 Khurana decides to
bring his King into the game King if
seven cross and does the same our King e
to still improving the position of the
King Knights the c5 and the now comes
Bishop to c3
if you can't really do anything with the
King just yet as you can see that black
is better you know blacks pieces are
much more active for example a mushroom
to h6 will always be a possibility for
black where you take away this entire
dark square diagonal from white from the
white king and well there's it's our
heart as it said what to play if you try
something like Knights - D - maybe with
ideas of a knight b3 Knight a5 maybe
going after the c6 pawn then black and
plate 96 and after you play Knight to b3
simply Bishop to f8 and you will allow
this and then push c5 and still it's
hard to say if black can actually make
anything from this but you haven't
accomplished anything with white and you
just have a funny night and on the edge
of the board you know
so after night to c5 we have push up to
c3 now comes 9 3 6 and g3 taking away
this very nice f4 square from Carlson's
night
we have Bishop to f8 and here comes
Knight - D - now Khurana it's definitely
going for that be 3 square Knight to g5
attacking the h3 pawn and here we have
h4 cousin goes back and now comes Knight
to b3 and here h5 it's very interesting
what happens if something like g5 is
played if you play g5 then you go into a
chapter son g5 Knight captures on g5 and
now f4 and this will be very good for
white because now after something like
before and Ice in between move but
should moves now you can go something
like knife to e6
but then f5 is coming or you can capture
on f4 but doesn't really do anything for
you at 5 and now after the knight moves
you've simply improved White's position
here and it will be it will be a better
game for white so after Knight to b3 we
have h5 by Carlsen Bishop to d2 and now
comes Bishop to d6 Bishop to d6 a very
nice move as White was definitely having
ideas of pushing f4 at some point and
Bishop to d6 prevents this we have c3
now taking away the d4 square from
since night and now this night is no
longer obligated the guarded d4 perhaps
it could go maybe to a5 to attack the
pawn or perhaps even a Rhema new ver
itself to some other square if if such
an opportunity arises c5 by crossing
there was no more way to improve the
position so now he decides to to pull
the pawn we have Bishop to e3 and who
now comes King to East 7 Kington d1 and
now comes King to d7 as Greece shook and
Peter Svidler are having a joined
commentary I think it was around at this
point where Carlson played King d7 that
sailor said that Carlson is definitely
making a reasonable progress in this
game King to see - we have f5 here and
now comes King back to d1 f chapters on
e4 this was also an interesting moment
as you do also have to figure out what
happens if you just push f4 also seems
like a very interesting move
now if G captures on f4 then you will
definitely play it captures on f4 and
black will be better now after the
bishop is moved and now comes Bishop to
e7 and there is no way to protect your H
pawn then black will just have a lot a
lot of points to push on the King side
and eventually win this game the problem
after f4 is that white can simply move
the bishop and ignore blacks advance and
then after g5 you can capture after
Knight capture she will play nice to d2
and you will simply wait to see what
black does of course you will never
capture on f4 and allow he captures so
it will still be like a I like a very
nice draws position so after King to d1
we have F capture Sonny formed by
Carlsen D captures on e4 and now c4
Knight goes back to d2 and now comes
Knight the c5 here Carson said in an
interview after the game that perhaps he
could have maybe wiggled around a bit
still trying to trying to find small
opportunities but
he still still played it and it was
enough for four Caruana Khurana simply
played Bishop captures on c5 Bishop
captures on c5 King e2 not defending the
f2 pawn King to c6 and now comes at
night to f1 this was a the point of why
it may be nice to see five by cross and
was a premature move now this night is
coming to e3 and from there it will be
an extremely powerful piece we have
before Khan capture Sun before Bishop
capture Sun before and now comes Knight
c3 as planned King to c5 and now comes
f4 we have it captures an f4 pawn
captures on f4 we have Bishop to a5 and
now comes F 5 by Caruana
G captures an f5 by Carlson and here
well there are a lot of ways to continue
this but Khurana simply takes the
opportunity to go for the for the force
the some draw variation he plays Knight
captures on c4 a very nice flashy move
for the end but also a very educational
move as if you are new to chess perhaps
you will you will appreciate why this is
a drawing move here King captures on c4
was played he captures an f5 was played
and it was at this point that the
players to agree to a draw and move 49
as there is nothing more to be done
because even well of course black will
gobble up both white pawns this point in
this point the problem is Carlson has a
dark square Bishop and the H pawn even
after all of these pawns are removed and
black is left with a bishop and upon
this pawn will come forward but after
the White King hides himself in the
corner the King will go to a light
square and you will not be able to push
it so let's just you know do any
variation just to show how this would
happen let's say white decides to give
up a pawn it doesn't really matter what
white plays any any moves will do you
know at some point you will have to move
and then after black will start pushing
it
here's pawn server that's white also has
to make a move
black will come here and after white
makes a move black will check him white
will go into the corner and now you will
either have to move away from the pawn
and then white will capture the pawn or
you will have to play something like
King to h3 white will have no more moves
as the King is guarding the GT Square at
the point is guarding in the g1 Square
and it will be a stalemate as the White
King has no legal moves so after each
captures on a5 they agreed to a draw and
Game three also ends in a draw and it's
very interesting how do you how do you
perceive this match is it like is it
like boring for you or is it like you
are very impressed by how how
well-prepared the players are because of
course most of I mean all of these
variations are engine variations so it's
basically the Battle of engines who can
memorize more moves but do you
appreciate that or would you rather see
like like a crazy King's Indian game or
something like that I don't know it's to
me it's it's very interesting to see how
how this happens and how will I mean
will you like create a small advantage
in the first hour of the game and then
try to push with that advantage for the
next six hours because that's seems what
Carson has been doing with the black
pieces so far in this match but yeah
it's it's very hard to do to create any
sort of an edge and a lot of people are
questioning how come it's the third game
now where black is playing for the win
but to me it seems like because white is
always looking for these small cracks
where he can create opportunities and he
can go for a win that it's actually one
of the reasons why it's actually always
black who is playing for the win because
it's just not possible to get an edge
out of the opening okay Carson didn't do
it in Game one because he really out
prepared Khurana for for that to Russell
mo but it's hard to say but yeah I'm
definitely as always interested in in
Europeans and how are you perceiving
this entire match so far so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to think
Carroll Krinsky in Stefan Jeffrey Turner
back from Mexico and Luka overall for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video serie
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon with some more interesting content
definitely would again for all the World
Chess Championship match and for the end
of the video here is another photo of me
and Michael John Buckingham but also of
the excellent subscribers that were able
to show up yesterday so thank you all
and I will see you soon